ET Aie
[Musique]
ET
demain est le problème du dilemme de Radiola si
rester dehors qui sait non non
tu sais taper dans tes mains bien que urucubaca qui
tu vis la vengeance ne t'aidera pas
Swing là-bas, vous faites les choix
Je pleure un plein de quatre trèfle
laisse savoir par lui-même ce que dit la voix
la réponse n'aidera pas je ne me vengerai pas
[Musique]
du bon son dans la boite et envoyer du bon
ambiance pour les gars
je ne vais pas
venger
bonnes personnes une boîte et envoyez la bonne
ambiance pour les gars
parce que tu es dans la cage a fait un
petit oiseau attendant que les louanges tombent du ciel
vous devez atteindre les poissons à gros yeux
car là seul tu ne vaux pas la peine de pleurer
Je veux croire en l'innocence et
[Musique]
que faire si le chat m'aide
la réponse ne fonctionnera pas nous appellerons non
non
il a du bon son dans la boite et envoie le bon
ambiance de la foule
je ne me vengerai pas
bon sonner la boite et envoyer le bon
vibrations pour
si
avez-vous déjà eu une idée nous prenons un
elle a fort son énergie électrique
[Musique]
c'est bien et envoyer
les mecs
je ne me vengerai pas
[Musique]
J'irai
Et merci beaucoup
déjà
avait du jus pour revenir mais pas être le
premier amour je suis ce fort 11 dôme
Prime Harbour Self Inn South ils abeilles
sont charme
jeté dans les cellules en pleurant des séjours perdus
Prier pour que le veilleur de nuit ne soit pas
avocat innocent oublié corrompu
failli avait un 12 mètres avec 40 c'est tellement
pourboire pour quatre feuilles en poche
caché une démo de pleurer en disant
Lost Son, faute du système qui ne le fait pas
dire bonjour à mes amis qui sont
là
tout ce qu'il veut c'est un peu ennuyeux
bayleigh salut
Donc c'est
[Musique]
je
déjà
Je l'ai passée à me parler fatigué avec
votre smoothie est décidé à l'empêcher de
nuit ne sois pas trop corrompu
pensée cool de la femme au lit avec un autre
crétin Ils disent que le système carcéral a
problème personne ne t'intéresse Tang paie
dans tes plumes de fumeur en tue deux si
volé tout de même demande plus de respect là-bas
dans le monde un animal blâme un système
qui ne veut pas accepter Bonjour à mes amis
sont dans la poussière cellulaire du système qui ne
vous devez accepter bonjour les gars c'est ce que vous
avoir là et tout est biblique, c'est un peu de ça
tout
[Musique]
c'est déjà
LA
dangereux ici
trois d'éleveurs sur le pied de fermentation
spectacles
faire peur à la vache puisque l'on aime les lettres
passé dans la vie
maxime, j'ai montré comment il fait partie de la
anpei aujourd'hui Lire plus vite
chanter avec moi en battant la paume de ta main
et chanter parler Où est-ce que je veux voir ce que
foule chantant en frappant dans la paume de la main
me parler en tapant la paume de la main
alors
les gars chantent avec moi en tapant dans la paume
de la main frappant dans la paume de la main et parlant
quelle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Le
la musique c'est déjà un peu ça hi hi hi
tout ce qu'il veut c'est un peu de ça
Salut
tout ce qu'il veut c'est un peu ennuyeux
et ne laisser que la base de la version morra
francophone
[Musique]
étapes nous avons un
je pense que c'est de la bombe
étapes qui vous blessent shumate
monchet Lemon fuck oubliera
Les portugais imaginent un toi futile
stratégie est qu'elle ne sera que le résultat de
jus de donné Remo basketball Ethos qui
arrivé ... que j'ai appelé sucer
les noirs se plaignent du matelas
des pas si longs
peut-être qu'il y a un bar pour oublier celui-ci
sushi Parce que t'es fan je te bouge
on dirait qu'il n'y a qu'un seul problème
Je ne suis pas médecine c'est ce bar mais ça
il y a un bleu fou ici
ne montre pas de Jésus
Jésus est
un des matelas
calme s'appelle
tout le monde soit
peuvent-ils prendre O
le basket est un bar je pense que ça t'a fait mal
les gens appelés le justifient toujours
toujours La Paz signifie que vous voulez juste
dîner
Je me sens comme du voyage papa
le basket et toi
et vous suivez, j'ai
post-générique et me demandait de fumer du
Jésus que Gemma
dos avec Gemma
Je peux quelle peur puis-je avoir un bar fait
ça fait mal tu as appelé
Monte est un [ __ ] de basket-ball citron si vous seulement
qui a joué la chanson Journey papa steps
qu'elle ne vient que de ses camions je ne sais pas
reste jusqu'à ce qu'il s'arrête Jésus est appelé
des haricots
à cause de toi, tu es l'un de ceux
[Musique]
là là
conception de prise
vous êtes
et j'ai déjà
ET Aie